Akira, we'll never see each other again anyway, so I'll
tell you one last thing: I
know what the man you're about to give yourself to really wants, and
it's made you submit.  To make someone do what you say, to have the
freedom to choose your own will, which is supposed to be yours alone, to take away the
dignity, soul, and pride that you have to be who you are
[Music]
Just giving up and depriving you of your true
self  Those lonely people who lack self-confidence, who are
always unsatisfied, and who only know how to communicate by making themselves big or attacking others,
want to affirm themselves even just a little, so they are only
comforting you.To
this day, I too am  I was the same as you, but
thanks to you, I finally woke up. I will never
hand over myself to anyone again. I
should leave, I should stay.
In this world where ideas are unknown, what is efficient and what is
correct?  No one will ever know, but
at least right now, I
want to do everything in my power to get out of front of this disgusting old
man as quickly as possible.
So,
Akira-kun, what are you going to do? You're
neither a machine nor a zombie. You're still a human.
[Music]
Hey, what do you really want to do?